my name is Chris Dancy I've been called
the world's most connected human I've
been collecting information about my
life my body in my environment for about
five years so I can search it review it
and access it if you take applications
sensors devices and services between 3
and 700 or monitoring meet any given
moment my life has changed drastically
over the last 5 years as of today I've
lost 120 pounds I can more easily focus
on tasks if I need to get a good night's
sleep I actually have little recipes to
make that happen every morning and every
night I capture my blood pressure and my
blood oxygen right now I'm doing really
good I'm at 98%
so I'm actually talking a lot I've got a
pneumo back on and lumo back allows me
to actually keep track on my posture the
thing I really liked about the house is
unless you're aware of it most of the
technology is not visible I have my nest
thermostat over here this is Rocco and
notice they were tagged sensors that
keeps track of their motion during the
day all through the house I've got very
very small little cameras up here we've
got my netatmo which is at just an
outdoor weather station I've got a cube
sensor in here monitors the air quality
in the room the humidity how bright is
it in the room the ambient sounds like
the TV too loud this is my office I
started when I was 14 collecting little
clippings and is anything I could find
it represented the little pieces of my
life and here is where my data
exoskeleton recharges everything goes in
here that recharges that's not on my
body
and like any good IT department I have
an infrastructure closet is probably
about 60 terabytes of data hacked up in
here the most interesting thing is most
humans are attached to at least 150
systems they just don't think about when
they swipe their credit card or they
walk into someplace so I'm not actually
that different than most people I just
talk about my relationship with that
information a lot differently I do see
the world differently just like the kid
from The Sixth Sense who kept saying I
see I now see information I see it
everywhere
you